ich habe mich gefragt wie weit kommt man
eigentlich wenn man 24 Stunden lang
jeden Zug in dieselbe Richtung nimmt und
dabei immer bis zu Endstation fährt
dafür habe ich morgen zum ersten Zug von
meinem Heimatbahnhof ausgenommen und bin
immer direkt in den nächsten Zug
eingestiegen der dann ebenfalls in die
richtige Richtung fuhr am Ende habe ich
drei Länder durch Kreuz und bin in einer
wirklich coolen Stadt gelandet viel Spaß
mit diesem Video
[Musik]
so Leute was geht ihr seht ich sehe aus
wie ich aussehe wenn ich ein neues
Reisevideo antrete ich bin gerade noch
hier in meinem Büro allerdings ist es
nicht weit von hier der Bahnhof und von
dort aus werde ich jetzt starten
fairerweise muss ich sagen ich nehme
erstmal den ersten Zug das ist in
Regionalzug bis nach Düsseldorf weil ich
da einen Termin habe und fahre dann
morgen von Düsseldorf weiter mit
Fernzügen straight in eine Richtung
immer der nächste Zug der kommt also wir
fahren jetzt erstmal nach Westen oder
Süden nach Südwesten so in diese
Richtung das ist die Idee der Challenge
mal schauen wie weit ich komme und das
Gleiche kann ich dann natürlich noch mal
mit Osten machen mit Norden ja ich bin
mir sicher unfassbar viel in kurzer Zeit
passieren und ich würde sagen let's go
Leute ich bin noch mal gespannt wie
teuer das denn insgesamt wird das erste
Ticket ist jetzt schon eine Reise Ticket
18,65 €, so das haben wir schon mal
gebucht ich muss ja dann auch also ich
bin ja safe ziemlich schnell noch im
Ausland ich weiß gar nicht wie ich da
dann die Züge buchen muss ich
wahrscheinlich dann am Bahnhof machen
und eins kann ich aber sagen wir werden
auf jeden Fall über 1000 km zurücklegen
da bin ich mir ziemlich sicher mal
gucken in welcher großen Stadt ich lande
das hier ist übrigens meine Hood also so
sieht das aus da vorne ist auch der
Bahnhof ich bin noch auf jeden Fall froh
dass sie überhaupt einen Bahnhof haben
aber von da fahren halt keine
Fernverkehrszüge ist das Problem so
schaut mal hier also da gibt's doch
deutlich hässlichere Bahnhöfe oder das
hier war übrigens der einzige Regio Zug
den ich schon am Samstag nach Düsseldorf
genommen habe und zwei Tage später am
Montag Morgen wenn ich dann von
Düsseldorf aus die große Reise
angetreten aber ich habe es jetzt
trotzdem mal mit einem berechnet
alles gut
[Musik]
so Leute was geht und damit einen
wunderschönen guten Morgen hier aus
Düsseldorf für mich geht es jetzt hier
zum Hauptbahnhof wir haben relativ früh
morgens das viertel nach Neun ich will
ja den ganzen Tag nutzen und dann
schauen wir mal wo der erste Zug hingeht
ich bin gespannt und ja ich beeile mich
jetzt erstmal weil ich muss noch
ungefähr eineinhalb km Lauf so Leute
angekommen Düsseldorf Hauptbahnhof bin
ich mal gespannt was da auf der
Anzeigetafel steht also das was Sinn
macht ist München der Rest geht auf
jeden Fall alles in der falsche Richtung
okay also erste Halt München so den Zug
kann ich auch noch buchen 85 €, ich habe
eine Bahncard oh ja okay dann nehmen wir
den Hintern
[Musik]
der erste Zug von Düsseldorf ging also
nach München und ich habe auch ziemlich
schnell gemerkt dass das irgendwie eine
ziemlich blöde Entscheidung war weil
München komplett in der falschen
Richtung liegt allerdings könnte man das
damit entschuldigen dass an dem Morgen
wirklich kein einziger Zug von
Düsseldorf nach Südwesten oder halt in
diese Richtung gefahren ist also die
erste Zug weil wir auf jeden Fall schon
mal ein bisschen fragwürdig muss ich
gerade sagen und habe es festgestellt
mein ICE ist zum Glück aber über
Frankfurt Flughafen Fernbahnhof gefahren
und ich weiß dass er immer ziemlich
viele fernzuge verkehren deswegen habe
ich mal kurz gemogelt so Leute ich habe
leider ein bisschen reingeschissen wir
können jetzt gleich einen Frankfurt
Flughafen Fernbahnhof und da muss ich
aussteigen ist eigentlich gegen die
Regeln aber ich erkläre euch dann mal
warum okay Leute was geht ich befinde
mich hier auf jeden Fall jetzt gerade in
Frankfurt Flughafen fährmannhof ich muss
hier aussteigen weil ich habe einfach
München gewählt und München ist komplett
in die falsche Richtung ich setze mich
immer ein oder dachte okay bevor ich
jetzt komplett ab dürfte mache ich einen
kurzen Absprung und deswegen bin ich
jetzt hier und wir schauen wie ich jetzt
am besten in südwestliche Richtung von
hier aus weiter Verkehre weil das war ja
auch der Plan let's go wir schauen mal
davon auf die Anzeigetafel ich hoffe ihr
könnt damit leben und nichts für mich
übel okay dann schauen wir mal ganz oben
Amsterdam dass wir eigentlich jetzt
wieder zurück lauffach kein Plan wo das
ist Basel könnte richtig sein ja dann
nehmen wir das glaube ich okay Leute
Basel gleich fünf let's go ich habe
gerade einfach 80 € und gesetzt weil ich
eigentlich bis München hätte fahren
sollen das hat 80 € gekostet mal gucken
wie teuer die nächste Strecke wird
perfekt Rolltreppe kaputt das geht jetzt
eigentlich sogar also ich zahl nur 52,55
€ let's go
[Musik]
für mich ging es dann also weiter ich
bin circa drei Stunden bis nach Basel
Gefahren über Offenburg Freiburg und
keine Ahnung was da noch so war Wetter
war in Deutschland jetzt nicht so
phänomenal das wird aber später noch
besser und es gab einfach in den ersten
beiden ICEs kein richtiges Essen Anbau
das gab nur so Schokoriegel und Kaffee
mehr hatten die nicht weil die Kühlung
ausgefallen ist zumindest haben die das
gesagt also ich glaube wenn ich die 24
Stunden Zug bin ich auf jeden Fall
danach verhunger ganz so weiter geht
so Leute ich bin auf jeden Fall jetzt
jeden Moment in Basel angekommen ich
muss sagen bis hier läuft es auch echt
gut also wir sind vor viereinhalb
Stunden losgefahren und sind jetzt schon
in der Schweiz ich glaube schon über 400
km zurückgelegt das Ding ist nur hier
gab es jetzt kein Essen im Zug davor
auch nicht deswegen muss ich auf jeden
Fall erstmal was essen bevor ich weiter
fahre sonst dreht durch und was ich noch
gar nicht so wirklich erwähnt habe ich
werde natürlich auch die Nacht
durchfahren in sofern es möglich ist ne
klar meistens ist ja so dass nachts
keine Züge verkehren wobei ist da glaube
ich auch Ausnahmen gibt in Deutschland
bin zumindest schon mal nachts um 3 Uhr
losgefahren oder so schauen wir mal wie
es in Frankreich oder Spanien ist
so Leute angekommen Basel dann schauen
wir mal was als nächstes hin geht auf
jeden Fall schon von hier fahren Züge
bis nach Mailand Deutsch
also ich muss mich erstmal ein bisschen
orientieren jetzt ich habe keine Ahnung
wo die ganzen Städte genau liegen
zumindest die meisten
okay Leute ich habe meinen nächsten Zug
gefunden das ist zumindest der einzige
der erstmal in die Richtung geht wo ich
hin will nämlich südwestlich und wir
überqueren direkt auch damit die Grenze
bis nach Frankreich das schon mal ganz
gut dieser Bahnhof hier ist echt fucking
groß Gleis 30 muss ich und ich muss mich
auch ein bisschen beeilen weil der hat
Verspätung eigentlich wäre dann nämlich
jetzt schon weg und auf jeden Fall
unfassbar gut in der Zeit das Ding ist
eigentlich bin ich jetzt im richtigen
Gleis aber hier ist einfach niemand ich
habe keine Ahnung was jetzt passiert so
ein Zug einfährt oder nicht gerade
stimmt das auch noch da oben und jetzt
ist es weg Scheiße okay alles gut da ist
der Zug das ist gut ich habe aber keinen
Ticket dafür und ich konnte über die
Deutsche Bahn aber auch keins kaufen
deswegen schauen wir mal was jetzt
passiert
keine Ahnung ob ich jetzt hier richtig
bin hier ist auch mal wieder niemand im
Zug aber ich setze mich jetzt einfach
mal hin Leute ich habe so hunger ich
muss auf jeden Fall gleich wenn ich in
Frankreich bin erstmal was essen dieser
Zug stand glaube ich aus dem 18
Jahrhundert so wie es aussieht
ich habe keinen Ticket kaufen können
[Musik]
okay Leute angekommen Mühlhaus jetzt
erstmal was essen eigentlich auf jeden
Fall ganz schön hier in mullhaus WoW
Eiffelturm dahin naja ich hatte gehofft
ich bin hier so richtig schön direkt in
der Stadt und kann mir hier was zu Essen
holen irgendwo nur leider sieht das
jetzt nicht so aus das Gute ist aber
erstmal wir können hier über Rot gehen
weil wir in Frankreich sind und zweitens
sie halten auch Fernzüge bzw
französische Fernzüge die gut für mich
sind weil die muss ich nehmen wir wollen
ja schließlich möglichst schnell
Weiterkommen ich weiß nicht ob ich hier
irgendwas zu essen bekomme oh Mann also
ich muss sagen so wirklich abfeiern tue
ich das jetzt hier nicht habe schon
schöne Städte gesehen ich dachte mir ich
hole mir jetzt
ab leider zu also man muss auf jeden
Fall sagen hier weiter ich hier in die
Innenstadt gehe dass du schöner wird
[Musik]
so Leute ich habe mir jetzt in der
Bäckerei noch ein bisschen was zu essen
geholt konnte leicht meine
französisch-skills von damals wieder
auspacken und jetzt geht's zurück zum
Bahnhof und wir fahren weiter okay Leute
also ich würde sagen die Innenstadt ist
eher so semig geil was umso besser ist
ein Zug nach Marseille 17:09 Uhr ich
habe gerade schon mal geguckt das ist
echt eine Strecke also komplett hier
runter bis nach Marseille ich war ein
bisschen mehr als 4 Stunden den nehme
ich okay Leute mein Zug steht und jetzt
nach 5 Jahren auch mal auf der
Anzeigetafel muss auf jeden Fall
zugleich sieben und ich musste mir
gerade noch zusätzlich extra diese diese
ziehen damit ich mir überhaupt ein
Ticket buchen kann ich habe jetzt
ungefähr 70 € bezahlt also gar nicht
mehr so günstig natürlich zweite Klasse
aber bis nach Marseille durch und da
komme ich dann heute Abend um 21:30 Uhr
an also ich bin mittlerweile schon
sieben Stunden unterwegs heute Abend
wenn ich da ankomme dann schon fast 12
dafür auf jeden Fall mein Abo drin
lassen würde ich mich sehr freuen wenn
ihr die Reisevideos feiert gerne
abonnieren weil das mache ich in Zukunft
noch öfter und ich muss das sagen ich
habe echt Bock auf Marcel ich war da
noch nie ich habe aber gehört es soll
eine echt schöne Stadt sein die Frage
ist nur wie lange ich mich da aufhalten
kann weil ich denke mal es könnte
realistisch sein dass ich heute noch bis
Toulouse oder so schaffe oder vielleicht
sogar bis Barcelona keine Ahnung wir
werden sehen
[Musik]
für mich ging es dann also weiter nach
Marseille ich bin über Dion Gefahren
über Lyon und das war es glaube ich auch
schon und ich muss sagen die
Landschaften waren wirklich 1A also ich
hatte einen komischen Sitznachbarn und
ich habe es echt genossen einfach in
diesem Board Bistro zu chillen und
bisschen so panoramamäßig rauszuschauen
könnte ja hier sehen also echt richtig
schöne Landschaften war ich überrascht
wobei gut südfrankreich ist halt einfach
sehr sehr schön genießt das hier ganz
kurz weil gleich sind wir am nächsten
Ziel ein Fluss ich war im Zug nach
Marseille aber auf jeden Fall schon
ziemlich fertig ich war da ja schon über
10 Stunden unterwegs um 20 Uhr waren wir
dann in Lyon und um 21:50 Uhr in
Marseille
oh Leute endlich ey ich bin so fertig
Mann Alter bin jetzt auch einfach schon
seit über 12 Stunden nonstop unterwegs
aber ich laufe jetzt natürlich erstmal
direkt zur Anzeigetafel und guck ob es
noch weiter geht ehrlicherweise habe ich
das aber vorher im Internet schon ein
bisschen abgecheckt da sah das jetzt
nicht so gut aus aber man weiß nie also
ist auf jeden auf jeden Fall echt krass
jetzt hier links die Fernverkehrszüge
die fahren alle nicht mehr wir haben
gerade mal fünf vor zehn also in
Deutschland fahren jetzt safe noch ICE
das finde ich echt heftig also hätte ich
nicht gedacht ich hätte gedacht ich
komme mindestens jetzt noch irgendwie
nach Toulouse oder so sorry Kamera war
bisschen dunkel dann ist natürlich auch
die Frage inwiefern es überhaupt morgen
früh noch für mich weitergeht ob sich
das überhaupt lohnt aber ich muss mich
jetzt echt erstmal ein bisschen ausruhen
okay Leute ich step jetzt erstmal hier
zum Hafen und ziehe mir da einfach ein
Hotel das sieht eigentlich ziemlich nice
aus und hier sieht es aber eigentlich
auch schon ziemlich nice das Alter wow
schaut mal hier runter
gradello fratello Marcel Camora also
erste Eindruck wie gefällt sie auf jeden
Fall echt gut ich bin jetzt auch schon
sehr random so hier gelandet hat ja auch
überall anders sein können deswegen
bleibe ich hier jetzt ist gut okay Leute
angekommen Hafen der ist hinter mir
sieht man jetzt gar nicht so gut ja da
kann ich sehen aber hier ins Hotel
ich habe es nicht vorher gebucht einfach
mal rein und hoffe dass sie noch ein
Zimmer für mich haben
für mich
perfekt
Leute ich bin so fertig aber was man an
dieser Stelle was sagen muss ich habe
das Hotel jetzt 11 € günstiger bekommen
als im Internet deswegen die freuen sich
auch immer wenn man einfach so Buch
entweder direkt im Hotel oder halt über
die hotel website so kann man auf jeden
Fall fast immer Geld sparen ich mache
mich mal kurz frisch dann gehen wir noch
vor die Tür wir haben jetzt auch schon
ja 10:30 Uhr also ich hoffe dass ich
noch irgendwas zu essen bekomme ich habe
echt Hunger und dann reicht es auf jeden
Fall auch für heute ich hätte jetzt noch
ein kleines Stückchen weiter wieder nach
Westen fahren können aber dann wäre ich
in so einer Pimmel statt gelandet dann
bleibe ich jetzt lieber hier in
Marseille und genießt die Zeit den Abend
und morgen und wir schauen mal was heute
Abend noch so passiert okay Leute
halbwegs falsch gemacht ich habe jetzt
gerade das Restaurant ausgesucht wenn
ich euch hier mal ein das ist bis 2 Uhr
auf super cool und das Essen geht
richtig lecker aus deswegen ich hoffe
ich bekomme da noch was zu essen weil
ich habe heute wirklich noch gar nichts
vernünftiges gegessen wir führen auch
die Challenge weiter überall wo ich
lande gibt es ein traditionelles Gericht
und einen lokales Bier also worauf
warten wir noch let's go eine Sache die
ich mich aber noch gefragt habe an die
Leute die sich auskennen ist das in
Polen oder Spanien oder Dänemark auch so
dass nachts gar keine Züge
so Leute essen war sehr gut also ich bin
jetzt echt satt und viel besser wieder
drauf als davor weil wenn man so lange
nichts ist es schwierig ich gehe jetzt
noch in so ein Studentenviertel das ist
hier um die Ecke das wird mir empfohlen
und ja da gibt's noch das Bierchen und
dann schauen wir mal ob noch irgendwas
geht oder ob ich mich dann ins Hotel
bewege weil ich bin echt fertig ey na ja
also was man sagen muss marcel ist auf
jeden Fall eine sehr hügelige Stadt hier
die ganze Zeit bergauf und bergab
einziger Nachteil man muss ja nicht
immer nur das Positive erzählen es ist
dicker
es ist an so vielen Stellen so dreckig
hier und überall sind leider Rad also
ich habe schon so bestimmt fünf Raten
gesehen und ich habe irgendwie Angst
dass vielleicht die nächste kommt das
ein bisschen schade na ja wow gebt euch
mal hier muss ich jetzt hoch was sieht
ganz cool aus alter ich muss sagen
angekommen
Bier probieren wir mal
ah ja ich hatte schon gedacht sehr
fruchtig feier ich nicht so und extrem
bitte zusätzlich das hat 8,20 € gekostet
muss los
durch
guten Morgen Alter wir haben 7:30 Uhr
auf mein Video noch was sehen
[Musik]
so Leute also guten Morgen aus Marseille
ja das Wetter ist wieder ganz nice die
Sonne ist noch nicht mal richtig
aufgegangen zumindest hier am Hafen noch
nicht angekommen ich mache mir jetzt
noch mal auf den Weg da oben zu dem
Aussichtspunkt und dann muss ich
eigentlich auch schon weiter wenn
irgendwie auch manchmal ein bisschen
dumm dass ich nur so kurz in den Stadt
bin aber ich fahre heute noch nach
Barcelona das liegt einfach daran weil
ich Mittwoch spätestens wieder zu Hause
sein muss weil ich in gewissen Form
manchmal ein bisschen beruflich
eingeschränkt bin sonst würde ich
natürlich auch noch länger bleiben nur
ich denke dass ich das bald doch
einpendelt dass ich dann halt wieder
mehr Fokus so auf Youtube legen kann ich
hoffe ihr könnt das verstehen
also manchmal bin ich wirklich ein
bisschen verstrahlt viele haben mir
gesagt ich muss unbedingt diese
Kathedrale anschauen wenn man von da aus
so wunderschön jetzt habe ich
anscheinend die falsche ausgewählt also
eigentlich soll ich da oben hin denke
ich mal und ich gehe jetzt irgendwo da
hin ich glaube bis da ganz oben schaffe
ich es jetzt für mich heute nicht mehr
okay Leute die Kirche habe ich gefunden
bzw die Kathedrale du hast halt echt die
falsche Mann ich bin so dumm
[Musik]
aber ich muss sagen ich finde hier sieht
es trotzdem wild aus hinter mir ist noch
mal das Meer oh da hinten ist sogar ein
Kreuzfahrtschiff ja Leute während ihr
jetzt die Glocken läuten denke ich ich
beende das Video hier für mich gehst du
mich jetzt noch paar Barcelona da wird
auf jeden Fall auch noch was kommen
abonniert super gerne den Kanal ich
hoffe euch hat es gefallen und ja ich
mache mich jetzt auf den Weg und ich
kann aber sagen Marcel eine richtig
schöne Stadt lohnt sich auf jeden Fall
mal für jeden der hier noch nicht war
das mal anzuschauen ich wünschte auch
dass ich noch einen Tag länger hier
verbringen könnte aber es geht leider
nicht die Arbeit ruft Leute das war es
von mir haut rein ciao